we told you at the top of the hour how
several GOP candidates embracing
President Trump came away winners in
last night's primaries now one of the
president's former foes in the
presidential election is finding himself
in a tight race for re-election and as
correspondent Casey steagle reports he's
now calling on the president for help
in Texas Republican senator Ted Cruz
knows what it's like to be
underestimated when I ran in 2012 nobody
in the state thought we could win six
years later he's a household name though
the incumbent is now involved in a
political showdown to keep his Senate
seat I feel so much more encouraged so
much more hopeful Democratic congressman
Bette O'Rourke elected in 2012 to
represent Texas's 16th congressional
district has built his momentum on a
large grassroots campaign were listening
to meeting with and bringing in everyone
Republican Democrat independent everyone
in Texas is important a message that
appears to resonate with voters with a
war in striking distance in this
predominantly Republican state according
to latest Quinnipiac poll Cruz maintains
a six-point lead 49 to 43 percent
but some polls suggest an even tighter
race a recent Texas lyceum poll put the
spread at just two highly unusual
analysts say in a state that practically
bleeds red the normal Republican margin
in Texas these days is somewhere 14 15
points senator Cruz is is awake at this
point so the mudslinging has ensued
Cruz's first TV ads came out at the
beginning of this month meta will work
is more extreme than he wants you to
know a roar countered with a fundraising
drive raking in more than one
million dollars to help fund
advertisements with a more quote
positive spin
while both crisscross the state trying
to win over voters I've told the people
of Texas if you elect me I will fight
for you and I believe I've kept that
promise
I'm just really excited about Texas and
feel very lucky to be a part of this
infos you remember during the
presidential campaign senator Cruz now
calling on President Donald Trump to
help stump for him in this bid for
re-election
Brett Casey steagle in Dallas Casey
thank you